este es otro de los problemas que me
mandó cortar yo el cual es bastante
interesante al igual que los otros dos y
de igual manera vas a ver que se
soluciona de una forma bastante parecida
a los otros dos y es justo lo que quiero
que vayas creando una intuición de cómo
se resuelven estos problemas pero bueno
qué dice el problema alicia está a 100
metros de blanca y blanca está a 300
metros de carlos y justo lo que quiero
que veas alicia es la letra am blanca va
ciudad letra b y carlos va a ser la
letra cm así que vamos a ponerlo de un
diagrama alicia está a 100 metros de
blanca y blanca está a 300 metros de
carlos y voy a suponer que blanca está a
la derecha de carlos y por lo tanto aquí
tenemos alicia por acá tenemos a blanca
y por acá tenemos a carlos a 300 metros
de blanca y de hecho la distancia de
alicia a blanca es de 100 metros esto va
a ser bastante importante por lo tanto
déjenme ponerlo de un color distinto y
la distancia de blanca a carlos es de
300 metros y después dice todos se
encuentran viendo
al frente y en la misma línea entonces
en la misma línea ya están pero además
todos se tienen que encontrar viendo
hacia el frente entonces todos ven hacia
el frente alicia está viendo en esta
dirección
blancas también en esta dirección y
carlos también y después dice todos
ellos viajan hacia el frente a
velocidades constantes y bueno no
forzosamente tienen que tener la misma
velocidad así que voy a decir que alicia
va a una velocidad de subíndice am
blanca va a una velocidad de subíndice
ven y carlos va a una velocidad de
subíndice y después dice en seis minutos
alicia alcanza a blanca entonces cómo
podemos pasar esta oración a una
ecuación bueno vamos a hablar de
distancia la distancia que recorre
alicia en seis minutos tiene que ser
igual a la distancia que recorre blanca
en seis minutos más los 100 metros que
había de diferencia como podemos
escribir eso bueno utilizando la fórmula
de la velocidad voy a decir que la
velocidad de galicia por el tiempo es
decir la distancia que recorre 'alicia
en seis minutos
esto tiene que ser igual a 100 metros
que es la distancia que había entre
alice blanca más la distancia que ha
recorrido blanca en estos 6 minutos es
decir la velocidad de blanca por 6
porque pasaron 6 minutos y alicia
alcanzó a blanca eso es lo que me dice
la primera ecuación pero después dice
que en otros 6 minutos seis minutos
después alicia también alcanza a carlos
en los siguientes seis minutos alicia
rebasa a carlos y bueno si escribo eso
de la misma manera en ecuaciones pues va
a quedar algo muy parecido fíjate bien
hablemos de distancia date cuenta que
seis minutos más seis minutos estoy
hablando de 12 minutos entonces la
distancia que recorre alicia en 12
minutos tiene que ser igual a 100 más
300 es decir 400 metros tuvo que
recorrer alicia para estar en el punto
en donde empezó a carlos entonces esto
va a ser igual a 400 más la distancia
que haya recorrido carlos es decir la
velocidad de carlos por el tiempo pero
el tiempo son 12 minutos la velocidad de
carlos de carlos noel y 100 perdón
perdón perdón
velocidad de carlos por el tiempo y aquí
ya tengo otra ecuación ojo las dos
ecuaciones hablan de la distancia y
ahora veamos que nos preguntan en
cuántos minutos blanca logrará rebasar a
carlos y justo tras esto vamos pero
habrá forma de escribir esta pregunta de
una manera que nos resulte una ecuación
y por la respuesta es que siguen
utilizando la misma idea nosotros lo que
buscamos es el tiempo pero sin blanca va
a alcanzar a carlos entonces tiene que
pasar lo siguiente blanca tiene que
recorrer una cierta distancia para
llegar hasta carlos y como podemos
escribir eso bueno pues la velocidad de
blanca por el tiempo este tiempo que
estoy buscando justo mi incógnita tiene
que ser igual a qué distancia hay entre
blanca y carlos son 300 metros por lo
tanto esto tiene que ser igual a 300
metros para llegar al punto inicial de
carlos más lo que haya recorrido carlos
es decir la velocidad de carlos por el
tiempo pero por el mismo tiempo por mi
incógnita y entonces si entendemos bien
qué es lo que está pasando ya podemos
despejar de aquí el tiempo y qué quiere
decir esto
va a alcanzar a blanca y si el isi va a
alcanzar a blanca entonces tienen que
recorrer 100 metros más lo que haya
avanzado blanca y después alicia va a
alcanzar a carlos entonces alicia tiene
que recorrer 400 metros más lo que haya
avanzado carlos y si blanca va a
alcanzar a carlos entonces tiene que
recorrer 300 metros más todo lo que haya
avanzado carlos en este mismo tiempo y
bueno siguiendo esta idea voy a despejar
a lo que yo quiero es decir el tiempo y
para esto voy a pasar la velocidad de
carlos por el tiempo del otro lado de la
ecuación con signo contrario entonces me
queda la velocidad de blanca por el
tiempo menos la velocidad de carlos por
el tiempo es igual a 300 de esta
ecuación y si ahora factor hizo el
tiempo que me va a quedar que la
velocidad de blanca menos la velocidad
de carlos esto multiplicado por el
tiempo tiene que ser igual a 300 lo
único que estoy haciendo es factor
izando al tiempo y ahora si si yo quiero
despejar el tiempo que tengo que hacer
pues pasar dividiendo esto que está al
lado del tiempo y me va a quedar que 300
entre la velocidad de blanca menos la
velocidad de carlos tiene que ser igual
al tiempo y es justo lo que yo quiero y
espero
que puede encontrar una expresión
equivalente para la velocidad de blanca
menos la velocidad de carlos utilizando
estas otras dos ecuaciones que tengo de
cada una de estas ecuaciones voy a
despejar a la velocidad de blanca en la
primera y la velocidad de carlos en la
segunda esperando que se pueda cancelar
la velocidad de 'alicia creo que por ahí
voy a resolver el problema tengo la
intuición de que por ahí puedo encontrar
la solución del problema cancelando la
velocidad de galicia y es más creo que
si no puedo cancelar la velocidad de
'alicia el problema no tiene solución
así que de la primera ecuación
despejemos la velocidad blanca para
sustituirla en mi ecuación del tiempo y
que me va a quedar que 6 veces la
velocidad de blanca esto tiene que ser
igual al 6 veces la velocidad del icia y
después si ahora yo divido ambos lados
de la ecuación entre 6 para encontrar el
valor exacto de la velocidad de blanca
me va a quedar que esto es igual a 6
entre 6 esto me da solamente la
velocidad del icia menos 100 en 36 lo
cual es 50 tercios pero lo voy a dejar
como 100 en 36 porque hoy te lo voy a
ocupar ahora de esta segunda ecuación
voy a despejar a la velocidad de carlos
en términos de la velocidad de alicia
y pueda sustituirla también en ecuación
del tiempo y entonces que me quedan 12
veces la velocidad de carlos es igual a
12 veces la velocidad de 'alicia menos
400 y de igual manera voy a dividir todo
entre 12 y entonces me queda que la
velocidad de carlos es igual a la
velocidad de 'alicia menos 400 entre 12
y creo que si me va a salir el problema
porque aquí ya estoy viendo que si se va
a cancelar la velocidad de lisieux así
que vamos a sustituir la velocidad de
blanca aquí vamos a sustituir la
velocidad de carlos aquí y vamos a ver a
que llegó que por cierto hay que
recordar siempre que es lo que queremos
lo que queremos es el tiempo en el cual
blanca va a rebasar a carlos siempre es
importante saber qué es lo que queremos
y no olvidarlo así que vamos a sustituir
estos dos sino que da la velocidad de
blanca pero la velocidad de blanca es
igual a la velocidad de 'alicia menos
100 sobre 6 entonces la velocidad del
icia menos 100 sobre 6 ya esto hay que
quitarle la velocidad de carlos pero la
velocidad de carlos es igual a la
velocidad de 'alicia menos
200 entre 12 la velocidad del icia menos
400 entre 12 y hay que tener cuidado con
este paréntesis de ahora ya que tengo
esto voy a distribuir este signo de
menos y que me queda 300 entre la
velocidad de 'alicia menos 100 sobre 6
100 sobre 6 es lo mismo que se encuentra
entre 3 entonces mejor lo voy a poner
como 50 tercios ya esto le voy a restar
la velocidad de cristian perfecto estas
dos se van a cancelar justo lo que
quería
- x menos me da más y 400 entre 2 es lo
mismo que 200 entre 6 que es lo mismo
que 100 entre 3 entonces más si entre 3
y esto va a ser igual a cuanto estos dos
se van que es justo lo que yo quería la
velocidad del icia menos la velocidad
del icia semana no la necesito y esto es
igual a 300 entre menos se encuentra a
tercios más 100 tercios es lo mismo que
100 tercios menos 50 tercios que es lo
mismo que 50 tercios entonces de estos
dos me quedase en cuenta tercios y si
voy bien 300 entre a 100 tercios menos
50 tercios y si si es 50 tercios aquí
vamos todo en orden
y entonces que me va a quedar de esto
bueno al dividir un número entre una
fracción es lo mismo que multiplicar ese
número por el recíproco de la fracción y
me queda esta expresión que tengo aquí
300 entre 50 se puede simplificar
bastante 300 entre 50 es lo mismo que 6
entonces estos 6 aquí me queda un 1 y 6
por 3 es 18 y ya encontré el tiempo que
yo quería el tiempo son 18 minutos que
esa era ajusta la unidad que estábamos
trabajando por lo tanto el tiempo en el
que alcanza blanca a carlos es 18
minutos y ya que encontré este problema
y como lo encontré de una manera muy
mágica y tal vez estratosférica porque
si hacemos las cosas bien date cuenta
que en el problema tarde o temprano se
va a cancelar una de las variables que
yo quiero y me va a quedar todo en
términos de puros valores numéricos si
utiliza la información que te da el
problema y además sustituye las
variables correctas entonces vas a
encontrar la solución de una manera muy
sencilla intenta resolver los problemas
siempre por esta misma manera y muchas
gracias a cortar yo por mandarnos este
problema